er gilt als ein nationalheld der
niederlande
der maler rembrandt harmon sohn von
rhein mit nur wenigen farbpigmenten
brachte er bilder zum leuchten wie kaum
ein anderer
seinen ruhm reicht bis heute dabei ist
er schon 350 jahre tot sein berühmtestes
bild die nachtwache hängt im amsterdamer
rijksmuseum und wird gerade live
restauriert zurzeit testet ein laser das
gemälde ab und analysiert die chemischen
elemente der farbschichten ob man so dem
genie von rembrandt näher kommt
der künstler der ein so großes bild malt
der muss natürlich irgendwie eine
komposition skizzieren
er hat zb die fahne des fähnrichs das
ist oben links die hat er zuerst etwas
anders positioniert wurde er hat den
kleinen berühmten mädchen was man sehen
kann auch erst eine art indianer musst
du noch aufgesetzt also er hat
sukzessive dieses bild entwickelt
während des magens und dieser
entwicklungsprozess ist natürlich sehr
spannend zu sehen
da weiß man wie rembrandt denkt da was
hat euch entscheidungen erfeld
rembrandts heimatstadt leiden liegt nur
etwa eine autostunde von amsterdam
entfernt hier wurde er 1606 geboren das
elternhaus steht nicht mehr die mühle
des vaters ist ein nachbau
aber die lateinschule die der junge
rembrandt besuchte gibt es noch und um
die ecke das atelier in dem er malen
lernte
ein video erzählt spielerisch seine
lebensgeschichte wer im siebzehnten
jahrhundert maler werden wollte musste
verschiedene songs lernen
landschaftsmalerei historiengemälde oder
porträts schon als kind malte sich
rembrandt immer wieder selbst und
trainierte so sein besonderes talent
emotionen festzuhalten
seine heimat leiden war eine liberale
universitätsstadt die durch buchhandel
reich geworden war und in der viele
künstler lebten
er war hoch motiviert und gebildet und
er wollte berühmt werden er war sehr
ehrgeizig und nichts konnte ihn daran
hindern der berühmteste maler seiner
zeit zu werden das hatte er sich
wahrscheinlich schon als kind in den
kopf gesetzt
mit 25 jahren zog er nach amsterdam
damals eine boomende handelsstadt die
neureichen bürger wollten sich
porträtieren lassen und rembrandt wurde
zum maler star in diesem haus lebte er
fast 20 jahre lang
heute ist es ein museum mit rund 280.000
besuchern pro jahr
[Musik]
hier sind die privaträume in denen sich
das familienleben abspielte
in zeiten von erfolg und glück aber auch
von großem leid
hier ist das kasten bild auf dem die
familie schlief und wo rembrandts erste
ehefrau saskia starb das hier ist
rembrandts atelier in dem viele seiner
meisterwerke entstanden sind und in
dieser ecke können wir sehen wie er mit
licht umging
hierhin ein tuch dass das einfallende
licht filterte und es weicher machte
auch in der druckkunst gilt rembrandt
als genie seine radierungen machte er in
der regel selbst so wie es den besuchern
im rembrandt haus vorgeführt wird
mit den serien drucken ließ sich schon
damals viel geld verdienen und dennoch
war rembrandt gegen ende seines lebens
pleite er lebt auf großem fuß und
bezahlte nicht immer seine schulden
deshalb ist diese sammlung hier auch ein
teil seiner konkursmasse und wurde schon
zu seinen lebzeiten verkauft
genau wie das haus und sein gesamter
besitz er zog in ein armenviertel und
malte weiter
die kunst war sein leben davon zeugen
auch die meisterwerke im amsterdamer
rijksmuseum die die besucher immer
wieder aufs neue faszinierend
[Musik]